max scherzer to the bump for the
nationals looking to bounce back from an
outing his last time against the blue
jays in which he allowed
five runs over five innings his previous
three starts allowed just one run over
19 innings with 24 strikeouts john
bertie hitting 200 on the season
swing and a miss
max scherzer has his first strikeout on
the game
a fastball by john bertie
did it with 95 mile per hour heat that
is a pitch in the middle of the zone
that verti could do nothing with
scherzer dialed in early quickly up 0-2
on garrett cooper
swaying and a miss
max scherzer with two strikeouts in a
one two three first inning he's off and
running on the hill for the marlins this
afternoon trevor rogers is sick start of
2021 13th of his career
389 or 387 rather on base
and a slugging percentage that is second
in major league baseball
against lefties as well victor robles
back leading off and he sends a shot
down into the left field corner
by john birdie at third base and victor
robles has led off this game
with a smoked double to left field
welcome back to the leadoff spot and
welcome back to scoring position
victor
here's trey turner the shortstop man at
third one out first inning
a 2-2 coming to turner and a swing and a
miss
holly mentioned it before that fastball
as good as anybody's in the game when it
comes to the swing and the miss and the
strikeouts now it is the 29th strikeout
he's picked up this season on the
four-seam fastball even inside the
strike zone and that's what's starting
to impress people and here's another guy
who's swung about well for the net so
far this year ryan zimmerman
a swing and a foul tip again leona hangs
on so how about that a lead off double
by roll blaze he gets to third with one
out but then trevor rogers strikes out
turner he strikes out zimmerman and he's
worked 14 consecutive shutout innings
marlins have their first base runner of
the game that'll bring up lewis brinson
here comes the 3-1
challenge fastball in there
nats will try and go around the horn and
they do
a four three
wipes out the lead off base runner and
max scherzer has two away in the second
look at castro gomes and hernandez to
face
trevor rogers here in the second
as this one is sent out to center field
brinson back near the wall makes the
catch check that harrison out there in
center field brinson's in right today
harrison makes the play
for out number one bring up jordy mercer
getting his first start in the series
swing and a miss he struck him on a
change up to get out of the inning
rogers has the work ethic he's got the
mental side of the game he's got the
will to be the best he can possibly be
here's monte harrison here's the one two
swinging a miss
max scherzer getting the
cutter by him
and he has his third strikeout so here's
trevor rogers now batting with nobody on
and two out here in the third
swing and a miss
fastball by the opposing pitcher and max
scherzer has his fourth strikeout in
three scoreless innings nationals have
two on
well they've got robles and he is out at
third
rogers bit of a spin move and then he
threw over to birdie who applied the tag
just in time to get roblace and it'll be
runners at first and second for ryan
zimmerman with two up here's the o2
zimmerman
to dead center
harrison back on it and it's gone
ryan zimmerman a three-run home run on
an 0-2 pitch from trevor rogers
and the nationals have a three-nothing
lead number 274 the career of ryan
zimmerman 107 off the bat 4 30 to just
about dead center top of the fourth and
the top of the order isan diaz
that's a nice change up below the zone
and max has his fifth strikeout
he's third in a row dickerson you're in
the crosshairs right now my friend
here's the o2 and that drills it
max pulls that cutter
and on an 0-2 pitch corey dickerson has
reached leading off the fifth inning
lift to fight as you get to the bottom
of the order here and monte harrison
who's old for three on the season
this one tapped back to max on the first
pitch
and that's an easy third out
here in the fifth inning
so max scherzer gets out of his first
jam of the ball game and the nats still
have a three nothing lead here's josh
harrison
one for two so far and yet again josh
harrison gets drilled he has been
pitched off the plate inside
consistently over the last couple weeks
and he's getting frustrated that he's
worn as many pitches as he has
josh harrison has
don't say a word to me for the rest of
the day body language right now trey
turner one on one out
ground ball diaz with the backhand flips
to devers and picked at first by cooper
what a double play behind trevor rogers
unbelievable job
so garrett cooper with an rbi
opportunity for the marlins who are
still trying to get on the board he
grounds this one to turner's left
and yet again max scherzer
quickly getting out of the jam tandy
leone comes in for his third at-bat
here's the 2-2
swing and a miss fastball buy it right
on cue
96 from scherzer and he's through the
seventh inning
so that puts two on for trey turner
with two outs here in the seventh
taps this one back to the mound
pop corrals it and i don't know what
he's doing with that throw
that was as bizarre as a slow toss to
first base as you will ever see
trey turner with elite speed getting it
down the first base line and zack pop
acting like my grandma was running the
first comes down madigan
he has motion down to the bullpen
that's going to do it for zach popp
he'll leave with the bases loaded in two
outs john curtis into the game he
inherits this bases loaded situation in
his 12th game this year
swinging a miss strike three got him
slider running off the plate
zimmerman offered and the inning is over
nationals leave them loaded we're headed
to the top of the eighth inning the
tying run is now standing in the on deck
sir for now duvall
with harrison taking off here's the
throw from gomes not in time
monte
they said that he came off the bag and
that'll be the second out
harrison had that base stolen initially
but jordy mercer hung around
and roberto ortiz instead he came off
the bag yeah you got a guy at the plate
who's one for six in this crew with a
home run against scherzer who's a power
guy
swing and a miss
max scherzer with 96 past that of duvall
he's through eight scoreless it's been
more than three years since max scherzer
last had a shutout takes the mounds for
the ninth inning having thrown
92 pitches and he will get the top of
the marlins order here in the ninth
inning
and diaz out toward left center field
gives it a ride turning looking and gone
a home run for esantiaz into the marlins
bullpen it's three to one well nissan
having his biggest game as a marlin this
season now the batter is john
bertie paint
matt scherzer drops 96 on the outside
edge
and he's stalking dickerson singled to
right center in the second the 1-2
swing and a miss
max scherzer
puts the finishing touches
on his first shutout
since the 2018 campaign with a 96 mile
an hour fastball for his ninth strikeout
of the ball game